[Musik]
Ich werde nur beim Wrestler sein Ich wollte
einer der besten Wrestler
der Welt werden Hulk Hogan war der Superheld,
der größer als das Leben war und ich war
fast wie ein abfälliges Schleudertrauma, du weißt,
ich bin ein Zugwrack Nummer eins
Wrestling's Train Race
[Musik]
Meine zweite Ehe dauerte 17 Jahre, also
konntest du deine eigene
Vorstellungskraft nutzen, um jeden Abend mit Ric Flair zu
sein, den ich brauchte.
Es war, als würde ich nicht die Liebe bekommen, die ich nach
Hause brauchte
Weil es
keine Blutversorgung
gab und wir in einem Raum mit ein paar Wrestlern saßen, die Kokain machten, lernten wir uns wirklich kennen und es kamen 35 Mädchen,
um uns zu sehen, und wir wählten die aus, die wir wollten,
drei pro Nacht war mein Limit,
du